.
>> Greg: YEP.
[APPLAUSE]
HAPPY FRIDAY, EVERYBODY!
YOU LOOK WONDERFUL.
I THINK.
SO HOW IS LIFE?
I KNOW YOU GOT INFLATION, YOU
HAVE CRIME.
WE'RE ON THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR
WAR.
THANK GOT THESE BOZOS IS THEIR
PRIORITY
IES STRAIGH
>> THOSE IN FAVOR WILL SAY AYE.
>> AYE.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, ON THIS VOTE,
NINE AYES AND ZERO NOS.
>> THE RESOLUTION IS AGREED TO.
>> Greg: NINE AYES LIKE A FLY.
IS THAT RIGHT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
BUT THERE'S A SHOCKER.
25 DAYS BEFORE THE MID-TERMS,
THE JANUARY 6 PANEL VOTES
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUBPOENA TRUMP.
THAT'S ABOUT AS SURPRISING AS
THE FINAL SCORE AT A HARLEM
GLOBETROTTERS GAME AND ABOUT AS
SPONTANEOUS AS ADAM SCHIFF'S
FACE.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
NO.
AND WHAT A CO INCIDENT.
IT HAPPENS THE SAME DAY THE
INFLATION NUMBER COMES OUT AND
HIGHER THAN HUNTER BIDEN ON FREE
CRACK DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
CRIME IS EXPLODING LIKE A CAN OF
SPRITE LEFT IN A FREEZER TOO
LONG.
THE BORDERS ARE AS OPEN AS THE
WEST WING'S WINDOWS WHEN JOE
FORGETS HIS LACTADE PILLS.
SO WHY NOT?
LET'S GO AFTER TRUMP SCREAMS THE
DEMS.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN IN MORE FAKE
TRIALS THAN THE CAST OF LAW AND
ORDER.
THE HOPE IS THE NEW CYCLE WILL
SHIFT FROM BIDEN'S DISASTERS TO
THE ORANGE MONSTER THAT CAN MAKE
ADAM KINZINGER CRY LIKE HE'S
CUTTING ONIONS WHILE HIS NUTS
ARE IN A VICE.
TERRIBLE.
SO WILL THIS DISTRACTION
OVERWHELM THE PUBLIC AND NOT
THAT THEY'LL FORGET IT COST $100
TO FILL UP A TANK OF GAS OR $15
FOR A PACK OF HOT DOG?
YOU HEARD RIGHT.
JOE BEHAR'S LUNCH COST $15.
IT'S TRUE.
FOR A PACK OF HOT DOGS.
DID SOMEONE BLOW UP THE OSCAR
MAYER PIPELINE TOO?
SURVEYS TELL US EVERYONE CARES
ABOUT, IT AIN'T JANUARY 6, IT'S
THE ECONOMY, IT'S CRIME.
JANUARY 6 IS LESS IMPORTANTS
THAN TODD PYRO'S TIME SLOT.
SOMEONE IS WATCHING.
PROBABLY YOUR FAMILY.
HERE'S WHY.
JANUARY 6 IS NOT EATING AWAY AT
YOUR RETIREMENT FUND.
IT'S NOT MUGGING PEOPLE ON THE
SUBWAYS AND NOT KILLING PEOPLE
BY THE TENS OF THOUSANDS LIKE
FENTANYL.
IT'S NOT ELEVATING POSSIBILITY
FOR NUCLEAR WAR AS WE POUR
BILLIONS INTO A CONFLICT
THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY AND I
DON'T MEAN KAT'S HONEYMOON.
THEY'RE ALL URGENT MATTERS.
PEOPLE ARE DYING ON THE STREETS
AND IN THEIR BEDS.
SO CLOSE TO A NUCLEAR DISASTER
YOU CAN TASTE DANA'S PLUTONIUM.
JANUARY 6, THAT'S THE CONCERN.
IT'S THEIR HAIL MARY.
NO WONDER SO MANY ARE LEAVING
THE PARTY LIKE A KEG IS EMPTY
AND THE COPS SHOWED UP INCLUDING
THIS SMART WOMAN.
>> I CAN NO LONGER REMAIN IN
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT'S NOW UNDER THE COMPLETE
CONTROL OF A KABUL OF WAR
MONGERS THAT DIVIDE US BUT
RACIALIZING EVERY ISSUE AND
STOKING ANTI-WHITE RACISM THAT
ACTIONIVELY WORK TO UNDERMINE
OUR GOT GIVEN FREEDOMS INSHINED
IN HOUR CONSTITUTION AND HOSTILE
TO PEOPLE OF FAITH AND
SPIRITUALITY, WHO DEMONIZE THE
POLICE AND PROTECT THE CRIMINALS
AT THE EXPENSE OF LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS.
>> Greg: THAT LADY MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE.
>> Laura: I SHOULD HAVE HER ON.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
BUT DON'T FRET, DEMOCRATS.
YOU LOST A TULSI BUT YOU GAINED
A LIZ CHENEY.
I'M STARTING TO THINK THE DEMS
SCREWED UP WITH THIS
INSURRECTION THEATER.
I THINK IT WILL BACK FEEL LIKE
ERIC SWALWELL AFTER AN EXTRA
LARGE BEAN BURRITO.
IT'S NOT GOING TO JAIL TRUMP.
IT'S GOING TO GET HIM
RE-ELECTED.
ANY TIME YOU WATCH THE HEARING,
YOU CAN SEE THE COMMITTEE WAS
MORE STACKED THAN DOLLY PARTON
PLAYING JENGA.
IT'S BURSTING WITH CONTEMPT FOR
TRUMP AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
A WITCH HUNT ARMED WITH
PREORDAINED CONCLUSIONS AND
EMPOWERED WITH UNLIMITED TIME
AND EFFORT ALL ON THE TAXPAYER'S
DEEM, WHICH SOME WORTH 3 CENTS
SINCE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
THEY'RE HAVING A TRIAL WHERE THE
PROSECUTION AND JUDGES ARE ON
THE SAME SIDE AND OPPOSED BY NO
ONE.
WITH THAT SETUP, I COULD CONVICT
TOM HANKS OF MURDER.
I JUST MIGHT.
JUST VALIDATES TRUMP SUPPORTER'S
SUSPICIONS THAT THE FIX WAS IN
AND ALWAYS IN.
DEMS ARE RIGHT.
THE HEARINGS WILL ANGER SOME
AMERICANS BUT NOT IN THE WAY
THEY THINK.
PEOPLE DON'T SWALLOW B.S. EVEN
WHEN YOU HIDE IT IN KILMEADE'S
SANDWICH.
FACT IS, THE COUNTRY HAS BIG
PROBLEMS.
ECONOMY, CRIME, THE BORDER,
HARRY AND MEGHAN.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
THEM?
THE DEMS WORK TO DISTRACT RATHER
THAN ATTACK THE PROBLEMS.
THEY SPEND THEIR ENERGY ON THESE
ISSUES INSTEAD OF POLITICAL
THEATRICS.
LIKE THEY'RE FRUSTRATED MOVIE
DIRECTORS.
RATHER THAN SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
HEAD ON, THEY FIND WEIRDER
THINGS TO DO LIKE CONVINCING
CHILDREN THAT THEY WOULD BE
HAPPIER STERILE.
THEY WANT TO AUDIT RON DESANTIS
RATHER THAN TACKLE THE BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT WE ASKED FOR.
NEVER MIND FOR SOVEREIGNTY.
FIND OUT IF HE REALLY TALKED
POLITICS WHEN HE WROTE OFF THAT
DINNER AT THE OUTBACK
STEAKHOUSE.
THEY WILL WEAPON ANYTHING
AGAINST THEIR ENEMIES.
LIKE TAYLOR SWIFT WEAPONIZED HER
MUSIC AFTER I DUMPED HER.
[LAUGHTER]
I MOVED ON, TAYLOR.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
SO I HOPE THAT DEMS GET
SHELLACKED AND LEARN A LESSON.
THEY NEVER ADDRESS A PROBLEM
UNTIL THEY CAN SEE THE POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES APPROACHING.
BY THEN, SO MUCH DAMAGE HAS BEEN
DONE, THE PROBLEMS ARE NOT ONLY
WORSE BUT PERHAPS UNSALVAGEABLE
LIKE CNN.
IMAGINE IN THE DEMS TRIED TO
TACKLE THE PROBLEMS.
THEY COULD PREVENT A LOT OF
SUFFERING.
INSTEAD, THEY DON'T.
SO NOW WE HAVE A WAR, WE HAVE
INFLATION, WE HAVE VIOLENCE.
IT ENDS THERE IF WE'RE LUCKY.
WE HAVE A WHITE HOUSE THAT NOT
ONLY CREATED 99% OF IT BUT CAN'T
DO SQUAT ABOUT ANY OF IT EXCEPT
TO TELL YOU NOT TO BELIEVE YOUR
LYING EYES AND RADIO ACTIVE
SKIN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> PERIOD!
>> WELCOME.
TONIGHT'S GUESTS, SHE GAVE
DEMOCRATS A PIECE OF HER MIND
AND IT'S THE MOST BRAINS THEY'VE
HAD IN YEARS.
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE,
HOST OF THE "TULSI GABBARD SHOW"
PODCAST, TULSI GABBARD.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>> IF HE'S THE FIRST THING YOU
SEE UPON WAKING, YOU'RE WATCHING
FOX OR HE BROKE IN TO YOUR
HOUSE.
CO HOST AND "FOX AND FRIENDS,"
TODD PIRO.
SHE'S LIKE A REESE'S PIECES.
TINY, SHINY AND SMELLS LIKE
PEANUT BUTTER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF.
HE BEATS PEOPLE WITH HIS SKULL
BY OUTTHINKING THEM.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND NWA
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
TULSI, SO I WOULD SAY FIRST
CONGRATULATIONS ON LEAVING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I WOULD SAY WELCOME ABOARD.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
ARE YOU GOING TO MAINTAIN THE
INDEPENDENCE OR JOIN A PARTY?
BECOME A SCIENTOLOGIST?
>> I'M AN INDEPENDENT.
NO, IS THE ANSWER TO THE LAST
QUESTION.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN
INDEPENDENT-MINDED PERSON EVEN
AS I'VE BEEN A DEMOCRAT FOR OVER
20 YEARS.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN INDEPENDENT
DEMOCRAT.
AND, YOU KNOW, ULTIMATELY THIS
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS GONE
INSANE.
>> Greg: YOU SAID SOME
INCREDIBLY BRAVE THINGS.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY SAID THE
STUFF ABOUT THE ANTI-WHITE
RACISM.
PEOPLE ARE SCARED OF SAYING
THAT.
THEY'RE AFRAID TO BE CALLED
RACIST.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO NOD ALONG
AND GO WE'LL JUST TAKE BEING
HATED.
BUT WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
WHOLE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
STUFF HAPPENING NOW?
YOU THINK IT WAS A COINCIDENCE
THAT IT'S NOW?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING, THIS
HAS BEEN POLITICAL THEATER.
HOW DO YOU HAVE A COMMISSION
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
BIPARTISAN, SUPPOSED TO BE
UNBIASSED AND OBJECTIVE BUT FROM
DAY ONE, IT WAS AN ANNOUNCEMENT
OF GUILTY BEFORE THEY BEGAN.
SO IT'S NO SURPRISE TO ME THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION.
THIS IS NOT WHAT IS ON THEIR
MINDS AND OBVIOUSLY MANY OTHER
THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH AND DEALING WITH
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
>> Greg: TODD, SHE MAKES A GREAT
POINT.
MORE PEOPLE ARE WATCHING YOUR
SHOW.
>> WOW!
ATTACKS ON THE 4:00 TO 6:00 TIME
SLOT.
YOU'RE FACTUALLY CORRECT.
YOU'RE A LAWYER.
>> I AM.
>> Greg: TWO QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
ONE, WHY.
WILL THE SUBPOENA DO ANYTHING?
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO SHOW UP.
IF CONGRESS TAKES BACK -- I
WOULDN'T SAY CONGRESS.
IT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
AND IF HE GETS SUBPOENAED,
SHOULD HE TESTIFY?
>> TO YOUR FIRST POINT, THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IN REGULAR LAW, I PRACTICE IN
SANTA MONICA SUPERIOR COURT.
A TWO-MONTH TIME WINDOW, WHICH
IS ALL THE DEMOCRATS HAVE IS
NOTHING.
I COULD GET A SUBPOENA DRAGGED
OUT WAY LONGER THAN TWO MONTHS.
YOU KNOW, DRAG IT ALONG, MAKE
THE PERSON TESTIFY IN THREE,
FOUR, FIVE MONTHS.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED ASK.
YOU DON'T THINK THIS WILL GET
DRAGGED ON BEYOND TWO MONTHS?
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT WILL GET
DRAGGED ON.
THAT'S WHY THEY WAITED TILL THE
LAST MINUTE.
THEY KNOW THEY WON'T GET THIS.
THIS IS THE LAST THING.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
JANUARY 6.
IT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
NOVEMBER 8.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SCORE POINTS
FOR THE MID-TERMS AND IT'S GOING
TO FAIL BIG TIME.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: KAT, DOES IT BOTHER YOU
THEY'RE USING OUR TAX DOLLARS TO
TRY TO SWAY AN ELECTION?
>> TAX DOLLARS BOTHER ME IN
GENERAL.
THE CONCEPT I'M AGAINST.
SO YES.
AND I AGREE WITH TODD.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WAIT
TILL NOW.
UNLESS TRUMP DECIDES THAT HE
WANTS TO DO IT BECAUSE HE THINKS
IT WOULD BE FUN --
>> Greg: THAT'S A LOT OF THE
REASONS.
>> WHICH IS A POSSIBILITY.
HE'S NOT A GUY LIKE AN AUDIENCE?
NO THANK YOU.
WHICH I'M A GUY LIKE THAT, TOO.
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND.
BUT IF HE DOESN'T WANT TO,
THERE'S NO WAY HE HAS TO IT'S
GOING TO FLIP TO REPUBLICAN
CONTROL.
YOU CAN DRAG IT OUT FAR LONGER
THAN THAT AS TODD SAID.
IF THEY REALLY WANTED TO, THEY
COULD HAVE HAD HIM BE ONE OF THE
FIRST.
THEY DIDN'T.
LIZ CHENEY HAS GONE ALL IN WITH
THIS.
THIS IS HER THING.
SHE HAD TO MAKE SURE SHE HAD
THIS INVITATION.
>> Greg: WELL, YOU THINK HE
SHOULD DO IT?
>> NO.
FOR ONE REASON.
WHY SHOULD THEY GET THE RATINGS?
WHY BE RELEVANT.
>> HE'S LIKE I'LL DO IT ON TRUTH
SOCIAL.
>> THAT'S HOW HE SHOULD DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
CNN NEEDS THIS, MSNBC NEEDS
THIS.
THREE GOING TO COVER IT WALL TO
WALL, 24 HOURS OF TRUMP AGAIN.
PEOPLE WILL WATCH ONE, THE ONES
THAT FEED OFF OF IT AND THE
OTHERS WILL WATCH TO DEFEND IT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT.
THREE OTHER PRESIDENTS IN OUR
HISTORY HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED.
A ALL THREE DIDN'T DO IT.
SO WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO TO
HIM?
CHENEY IS GOING TO PUT HIM ON
SECRET DOUBLE PROBATION?
LITERALLY TRIED EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO GET HIM PUT BEHIND BARS
TO GET TO THE POINT HE COULDN'T
RUN.
NOW THEY'LL HAVE HIM COME OUT.
EVEN IF HE DID, WHAT WOULD IT
HAVE BEEN?
THEY ALL WOULD HAVE MADE THEIR
SPEECHES AND YOU'RE OUT OF
ORDER.
SO IT'S A WASTE OF HIS TIME.
HE NEVER LISTENS.
MR. PRESIDENT, DON'T PUNCH DON'T
AND DON'T BRING THEM UP.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO SAY THIS,
IMAGINE TYRUS, HOW GREAT THIS
SHOULD WOULD BE IF HE TESTIFYING
EVERY DAY.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO WORK.
WE WOULD JUST COME IN HERE
AROUND ROLL TAPE.
>> AND IT'S NOT JUST PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
WHENEVER SOMEONE OR A GROUP
DECIDES TO MAKE ACCUSATIONS
AGAINST YOU WITH NO FOUNDATION
OR NO BASIS FOR ANYTHING OTHER
THAN JUST TO RUIN YOU OR
BESMIRCH YOUR NAME, THE WORTH
THING TO DO IS ENGAGE THEM.
THE ONLY THING YOU HAVE TO BE
MADE CLEAR WITH A DAMAGING
ACCUSATION OR ALLEGED CRIME
THROWN AGAINST YOU BY PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IS TO
ENGAGE.
THE ONLY THING YOU HAVE TO BE
GOOD WITH IS YOUR FAMILY,
FRIENDS AND JOB.
YOU DON'T OWE THEM AN
EXPLANATION.
IF HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG,
WHICH THE FBI SAID HE HASN'T, HE
HAS NO POINT.
DON'T FEED THE FIRE.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: LIKE I SAID TO MY
MASSEUSE, WE'LL HAVE TO LEAVE IT
THERE.
UP NEXT, BIOLOGICAL MEN GET THE
SHAFT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DRAFT.
[APPLAUSE]